[Music]  gushes over his baby girl you're the bet  you're gonna be the best dad you are the  sober one they do new stuff all the time  and it's constantly entertaining it's  crazy  well yeah maroon 5 frontman was a guest  on Tuesdays tonight's show where he  opened up about his nearly six month old  daughter dusty rose Levine revealed he's  got some friendly competition going with  his wife Behati Prinsloo / Dusty's first  word I've been working dad died like  hard you know like you we work on it  really hard and you do slip it into  every single thing you say like if she's  being cute like oh my God look how cute  you are dad and my wife is working mama  so so it's like it's a bits of battle to  the finish it's clear Lavigne is loving  fatherhood here's what he told et last  year we were born to be a parent that's  what we're here for really all the  others is great but it's not what we're  here for  you